c'est une tradition en voie de
disparition
dans un lieu emblématique au coeur de
mumbai
un savoir faire transmis de génération
en génération
[Musique]
quel avenir pour la caste des lobbies
les laveurs de linge nous sommes ici au
coeur de la plus grande laverie à ciel
ouvert du monde
plus d'un million de vêtements sont
lavés séchés repasser si chaque jour
avant d'être redistribués à des hôtels
des hôpitaux ou à monsieur et madame
tout le monde
c'est une activité traditionnelle plus
que centenaire qui en raison de la
modernité est en pleine transformation
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
6h30 du matin le quartier d'aller civ
s'activent peut appeler les daubes ils
ont encore une fois travaillé tard un
dur labeur du matin au soir comme ceux
repassage dans l'obscurité avec des
faire chauffer au charbon de bois
sachez nous travail 363 jours par m il
ne prend donc deux petits jours de
vacances
son salaire annuel est de seulement deux
mille dollars sa journée commence par la
livraison du linge à travers la ville
comme des salariés des salles les daubes
ils ont inventé un système qui leur
permette gérer la distribution de ces
centaines de milliers de vêtements aux
quatre coins de la ville sans en perdre
un seul morceau
une fois de retour au quartier d'auby
gâte
la journée de sachy nous est loin d'être
terminée car il ne fait pas que livrer
linge il le lavaux si nos gars c'est la
première grande révolution que vivent
les daubisse depuis quelques années ceux
qui lavent à la machine ne sont pas
mieux payés mais ils peuvent espérer
travailler quelques heures de moins
chaque jour le quartier compte
maintenant 400 machines à laver et
sécher
chacune de ces machines peuvent faire le
travail de cinq personnes
enfin les voilà donc
victor sada recentrer l'aide à ces
barrages aux femmes d'être aujourd'hui
qu'après le gard à celle de l'appareil
aujourd'hui le nombre de travailleurs
d'eau biz a chuté à 5000 à bio à agay
d'autres bêtes il aurait donné il n'y a
pas que les cols blancs des chemises qui
faussent du souci au dos vise ceux de la
ville de mumbai aussi les hauts
fonctionnaires leur donne du fil à
retordre la municipalité refuse pour le
moment de classer les sites comme
patrimoniale et donc de le protéger
les doubistes se sentent trahis et la
cause est devant les tribunaux depuis
plusieurs années il y a de gros intérêts
financiers derrière tout ça idéalement
situé au centre ville le mètre carré
dans le quartier vaut une fortune
l'espace de chacun de l'avoir coûterait
au moins trente mille dollars
[Musique]